de noël et bien tout d'abord à 12 heures
tino rossi nous chantera petit papa noël
ensuite téléfilm blanche neige et les
sept nains un nom avec dans le rôle des
mains du narines avec dans le rôle des
nains tino rossi qui nous chantera petit
papa noël dans le rôle de blanche neige
la jeune et ravissante fraîche
comédienne line renaud
ensuite un spot publicitaire pour la
promotion du nouveau disque de tino
rossi qui nous chantera une nouvelle
chanson de son dernier album
petit papa noël se réfère 3 un événement
en effet pour la première fois et faire
3 diffuse un film un film japonais
d'horreur leone et le kung-fu mois ian
read sur tf1 un film d'alfred hitchcock
les 38 marche et un palier c'est un film
à suspense plein de rebondissements
l'action de ce film se situe de nos
jours on découvre sur nos trottoirs du
boulevard raspail 1 qatar mort
grâce à ses papiers on sait tout de
suite qu'il s'agit de monsieur de rouge
tout de suite deux suspects madame de
rouge et l'amant de monsieur de chloride
a fait manquer laurent c'est comme ça
bon c log un film à suspense maintenu
rebondissements le téléspectateur se
demandent avec angoisse tout comme
l'inspecteur maigret qui est le coupable
le coup pas tout la coupe intervenants
on ne sait pas qui a tué à la fin on le
sait on sait que c'est madame de rouge
je ne vous en dis pas plus en fin de
programme
retransmission en direct du théâtre des
champs elysées du concert donné au
bénéfice des oeuvres sociales du 16e
arrondissement par le philharmonique de
berlin qui vous interprétera la 9e
symphonie de beethoven dirigé par dix
la ferme on est soit dirigée par
l'auteur lui même
il est mort nous apprenons à la minute
même le dessin le décès de monsieur
beethoven nos plus sincères condoléances
à toute la famille
bonne soirée à tous au revoir